il y a encore quelques années nous
n'avions pas conscience de nos actes sur
l'écosystème
aujourd'hui grâce à une communication
importante sur ce sujet nous avons bien
plus conscience de nos actes mais il
existe peu d'endroits où on nous apprend
à agir comme il le faudrait des endroits
où on nous enseigne l'attitude éco
citoyenne c'est en faisant ce constat
qu'un établissement des hauts de
sainte-marie a eu l'idée d'intégrer de
manière plus concrète
un programme permettant de sensibiliser
efficacement les élèves de leur collège
donc le projet a démarré il ya cinq ans
et en fait suite à une demande du
principal adjoint madame dufour à
l'époque qui nous a proposé un concours
entre des élèves de du collège de la
réunion du collège beauséjour et
l'afrique du sud sur le développement
durable ce qu'on pouvait apporter chacun
à son île où son pays est donc on a
recruté un certain nombre d'élèves
volontaires et quand on a vu la
motivation qu'ils avaient eu à faire ce
travail on a décidé de continuer sur
quelque chose concernant le
développement durable
donc on a demandé aux élèves de chercher
un petit peu sur internet qui pouvaient
exister comme type de projet et on est
tombé sur l'éco écoles
au fur et à mesure dans l'année ces
élèves ont participé et au jardinage et
la prise de contact avec une association
qui étaient les amis des plantes et de
la nature la ppn qui nous ont fourni des
plantes endémiques que finalement les
élèves qui faisait jardinage entre midi
et deux ont fini par planter à la fin de
l'année donc maintenant on a dans ce
collège depuis quatre ans quelques
espèces quelques exemplaires d'espèces
endémiques qui pousse avec des petits
panneaux inscrits est fixé sur des gros
rochers donc tous les élèves peuvent
lire tout le monde c'est vraiment
retrouver le conseil général est venu la
mairie est venu le parc national est
venu ont tous retrouvé enfin sauf que ce
projet qui a fédéré comme ça un grand
groupe de personnes grâce aussi au fait
que les élèves étaient très volontaire
puisque quand on on appelle une
entreprise on appelle une collectivité
locale en disant on est 100 150 élèves à
travailler sur ce projet on a tout de
suite du poids et ça a réuni tout le
monde souhaitait la cne très sympa dans
l'andante projet devant un tel succès et
une telle implication des élèves les
professeurs et l'ensemble du personnel
du collège les ont soutenus et
encouragés à s'impliquer davantage
ils ont proposé des solutions pour gérer
l'eau les déchets et l'électricité là
encore la prise de conscience a été
immédiate et surtout efficace grâce à
cela les élèves ont fait preuve de
solidarité et apprennent le savoir vivre
ensemble
l'année dernière donc un travail autour
du thème de des déchets est
particulièrement des déchets
alimentaires
parce que ce que je regrette c'est que
quand on voit les problématiques de
de la faim dans le monde quand on voit
même près de chez nous des jeunes qui
ont du mal à ne serait-ce a à manger
régulièrement et je parle même de même
pas équilibré c'est manger tout
simplement on a fait des pesées aussi de
deux poubelles avec les restes
alimentaires pour là aussi essayé de
tendre vers moins de 2
déchets alimentaires et pour
sensibiliser les élèves sur cette
priorité à mon sens de respect de la
nourriture et de respect là aussi du
travail des uns et des autres bien sûr
des cuisiniers qui font les repas les
agents qui sert voyant un tel engouement
pour ce projet le conseil général a
décidé d'apporter son aide
il a donc subventionner les travaux
comme l'installation et la pose de
panneaux solaires avec un tableau de
consommation d'énergie permettant aux
élèves d'avoir une vision sur la
production d'énergie
la réunion a été déclaré patrimoine
mondial de l'humanité par l'unesco pour
44 % de sa superficie
ce titre est une preuve incontestable
que notre ils méritent d'être préservés
cette préservation sera durable en
apprenant à nos enfants comment
entretenir écologiquement notre
département